der rekord ist geknackt ein
forschungsteam aus michigan hat den
kleinsten computer der welt gebaut seine
kantenlänge beträgt nur achtung 0,3
millimeter das ist absolut nichts ein
reiskorn sieht im vergleich dazu riesig
aus kriegs- und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
entwickelt wurde der mini mini mini mini
computer im rahmen eines neuen duells
zwischen den ingenieuren und
ingenieurinnen von ibm und der
university of michigan immer wieder
übertrumpfen sich die beiden beim bau
des ganzen computers der welt doch jetzt
steht tatsächlich die frage im raum ob
der neu entwickelte computer überhaupt
als vollwertiger computer zählt der
hintergrund von 2014 bis anfang 2008 10
hielt die university of michigan den
weltrekord für den kleinsten computer
der welt der so genannte michigan micro
mode war nur zweimal zwei mal vier
millimeter klein dabei aber voll
funktionsfähig nur noch mal um seine
winzigkeit zu verdeutlichen in einem
fingerhut würden tatsächlich fast 150
dieser mini computer platz haben
auch wenn er nicht an strom
angeschlossen war konnte er seine
programmierung und datenspeichern und
der michigan micro mode gilt als
vollständiges autonomes computersystem
so die pressemitteilung der university
of michigan die anforderungen dafür
erfüllt ihr tatsächlich in jedem punkt
das computersystem muss in der lage sein
daten aufzunehmen die eingegeben wurden
zudem muss er die fähigkeit haben diese
zu verarbeiten und zu speichern und
entscheidungen darüber treffen zu können
was als nächstes zu tun es aufgebaut ist
der mini computer in gestapelten
schichten die untereinander
kommunizieren können zudem enthält er
eine solarzelle die ihn mit 20 nano watt
versorgt und alleine durch das auffangen
des umgebungslicht es kontinuierlich
laufen kann im standby modus verbraucht
das gerät etwa eine million mal weniger
strom als ein herkömmliches handy im
standby modus und auf seine anwendung in
verschiedenen praxis bereichen musste
der minicomputer auch nicht lange warten
das michigan forschungsteam wurde
überflutet von anfragen
nicht nur schnecken fachleute zeigten
sich interessiert sondern auch experten
und expertinnen aus dem medizinischen
bereich auf der basis des mini computers
wurden beispielsweise bereits indiziere
sensorsysteme entwickelt die direkt aus
dem menschlichen körper senden können
doch dann kamen im februar 2018 der
gegenschlag von ibm
der durchmesser hier nur 1 x 1 mm mit
mehreren hunderttausend transistoren
also elektronischen halbleiter elementen
wirklich krass klein denn der ibm mini
rechner ist kleiner als ein grobkörniges
salzkorn doch seine leistung ist für
diese größe enorm und vergleichbar mit
der eines x86er pcs aus den 90er jahren
aber hey die test von computer von
damals waren nicht nur riesig sondern
auch unhandlich und schwer wirklich
beeindrucken was sich in den jahren
getan hat laut den ibm entwicklern
entwicklerin soll seine herstellung
weniger als zehn euro kosten und ibm hat
großes mit dem vor
er könnte in viele gängige konsumgüter
integriert werden und produkte so
fälschungssicher machen
jetzt hat die university of michigan
allerdings wieder zurückgeschlagen ihr
neu entwickelter computer hat nur eine
kantenlänge von 0,3 millimetern und ein
reiskorn sieht im direkten vergleich mit
einem computer aus wie ein riese mit
integriert prozessoren photovoltaik
sowie funk sender und empfänger erst in
der lage temperaturen in zeitintervalle
umzuwandeln
durch den vergleich mit einem konstanten
zeit in der wahl kann er so die
temperatur bis auf 0,1 grad celsius
genau bestimmen
und man kann sich sicher schon denken
eine großartige anwendungsmöglichkeit
für den mini rechner wäre der
medizinische bereich er könnte
beispielsweise temperaturveränderung
inzell gruppen messen und somit tumoren
aufspüren denn es gibt studien die
nahelegen dass krebstumore höhere
temperaturen als reguläres gewebe
aufweisen das müsste natürlich erst noch
alles genau getestet werden doch zurück
zu dem computer selbst denn da gibt es
noch eine kuriose sache zu berichten
sowohl bei der ibm entwicklung als auch
bei dem neuen produkt aus michigan sind
sich experten und expertinnen gar nicht
so sicher ob diese beiden mini computer
überhaupt als solche bezeichnet werden
dürfen denn im gegensatz zu dem michigan
micro mode verlieren
sie ihre früheren programmierungen und
daten sobald ihnen der strom fehlt dazu
david bloom ein experte für
elektrotechnik diese sind nicht sicher
ob sie computer genannt werden können
oder nicht es ist eher so etwas wie eine
auslegungssache ob sie es tatsächlich
die erforderliche mindestpunktzahl i tät
haben dabei ist eine sache dennoch ganz
sicher durch das nötige duell der beiden
konkurrenten in den usa entstehen so
immer neue entwicklungen und techniken
die uns früher oder später auch im
alltag enorm weiterhelfen könnten und
jetzt hier klicken
das war nämlich eine videopremiere auf
dem englischen klicks um kanal wegen
gibt es hier wenn ihr alle videos auf
jeden fall zuerst sehen wollt dann
abonniert klicks um auf jeden fall auch
auf englisch ich freue mich auf euch
auch dort stay tuned